hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute habe ich ein leckeres
partie rezept für euch eine richtig
coole rezept für silvester zum beispiel
aber auch einfach mal so wenn ihr
irgendwo eingeladen seit etwas tolles
zum mitnehmen murat das ist ein salat
des giga ich habe nämlich einen leckeren
takko salat gemacht und zwar ist es ein
salat in kammern gut vorbereiten kann in
den kühlschrank lagert und einfach kurz
vor dem servieren dann noch diese
leckeren knusprigen takko chips mit
draufsetzen und ich will jetzt einfach
mal sagen wir starten direkt wir müssen
zuerst nämlich zwei komponenten
herstellen die gekocht werden und zwar
ist einmal die hackfleischsoße und die
salsa sauce und die müssen dann abkühlen
und danach kommt eben der salat direkt
zusammen deswegen ja also allerdings
gibt weder richtig hübsch weil es
richtig toll aus guckt man da die
verschiedenen schichten an
ja es geht nicht ich finde das ist eine
hauptspeise also ich gar nicht schauen
also eigentlich kann man das weg sich
als hauptspeise er wirklich wahnsinn
jetzt legen wir einfach direkt los für
die hackfleischsoße brauche ich zwei
esslöffel olivenöl eine zwiebel 500
gramm hackfleisch da habe ich jetzt
rindfleisch ich brauche einen esslöffel
tomatenmark 200 gramm tomaten aus der
dose des bereits gestückelte also das
ist eine halbe dose ich brauche etwas
wasser und hier habe ich bereits eine
dose mais und eine dose kidney bohnen
abtropfen lassen und später für die
salsa sauce brauche ich eine zwiebel der
grüne paprika hier habe ich eine
chilischote
ich habe ich die zweite hälfte der
dosentomaten also auch 200 gramm zwei
esslöffel braun und zucker 2 esslöffel
essig und zehn gramm stärke und später
dann eben noch ein bisschen gewürz ich
starte jetzt zuerst mit der salsa sauce
weil die er gleich ein bisschen ein
kochen muss und dafür nämlich die
zwiebel und die grüne paprika und auch
die chili und die werden dann fein
gewürfelt
ich nehme für die salsa sauce jetzt
erstmal nur eine halbe chili das ist
eine habanero chili schote und sie sind
als ziemlich scharf müsste einfach
selber abschmecken abstimmen wie viel
schlaf ihr also wie viel chili oder
eingeben wollen
gebe ich etwas olivenöl in einem topf
den hab ich jetzt bereits erhitzt
da kommen jetzt die zwiebel und die
chinesische
dann ist ja echt aufpassen wenn ihr mit
silly arbeitet also eigentlich hätte ich
jetzt auch handschuhe ansehen müssen
weil die hände danach recht scharfen für
zahntechniker hand in berührung kommt
jetzt wird es da drin so ein bisschen
angeschwitzt jetzt gebe ich direkt die
tomaten mit rein
bis da ich aufpassen auch beim anbraten
das sieht echt richtig ihnen hans
schärfe jetzt gehe ich auch direkt den
rest mieter zogen also auch den braunen
zucker essig und etwas stärke ich gebe
es noch nicht alles mit rein und dann
darf das einfach so vor sich hin köcheln
so etwa fünf bis zehn minuten bei
geringer hitze
jetzt können die soße abschmecken schon
mal mit salz und pfeffer
ob sie wirklich extrem scharf morath ich
lieb' ich liebe ja ich liebe amerika mag
ich mehr pfeffer noch ein
also ich hab es auch die ennahda da
hinten im laufgitter und wir haben jetzt
weg gestellt weil nicht dass die schärfe
mit zu ihr kommt also wirklich extrem
scharfe liegt in der luft
möchtest du mal probiert ich habe mal
gehört die mexikaner essen in
wirklichkeit gar nicht so zur schau
gehört denn er kommt ab und ich habe
gehört dass die sachen was typisch
mexikanisch wissen dass es in indien
mexiko gar nicht gibt
okay vielleicht vorstellen da kommt ja
später noch was anderes mit dazu alte
die soße da wird schon gut scharf sein
wo ich hinfahre steht kurz morath wollte
ich habe richtig sei aber ich kam es nur
zu tacos kenntnis richtig gut vorstellen
richtig gut
das ist so schade ich habe auch den
vorderen teil der chilischote genommen
da war nicht so ganz viele kerne mit
drin also von daher geht also ich finde
sich eine schöne schärfe richtig schaut
wirklich ja und während die soße ist
noch vor sich hin köchelt oder kocht des
sanierers sagen kann ich hier schon mal
das hackfleisch anbraten gebe ich auch
wieder zwei esslöffel olivenöl in die
pfanne ganzen haus dauere diese ausdauer
in nein
und dann gebe ich das gleich mit rein
das hatte ich vorher eingefroren und
aufgetaut das hab ich halt immer
hackfleisch voraus
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die zweite zwiebel klein würfeln
jetzt gebe ich die zwiebel mit rein also
dann wenn das hackfleisch krümelig
gebraten ist so schnell ist keine übung
produkt besteht sich schnell mit der
maus von mexiko mit einem gut hierdurch
rennen
es war auf meinem kind fernhalten lassen
jetzt gibt es noch ein esslöffel
tomatenmark mit rein
da kommen jetzt die tomaten und mit rein
und etwas wasser verspüre ich immer
gerne die dose auch aus aber die schale
jetzt gibt's als gewürz ein bisschen
kreuzkümmel reihen hat so eine prise
dann natürlich salz und teelöffel
kreuzkümmel ganz wichtig geld als nicht
in anderen kümmel das war doch immer
noch etwas kühler
rage magazins sind und hier wird sich
jetzt noch mit bisschen tabasco als noch
nicht scharf genug ich gern was sagt er
übrigens in japan am ende über fährt was
kümmert es mich dass er nicht
aufspringen
ich fand es nicht jetzt hat sich das
hackfleisch ein kochen bis die
flüssigkeit verdampft ist in der
zwischenzeit räume ich hier noch kurz
auf und dann geht es gleich weiter
die soße um das hackfleisch durften
jetzt ein kochen das war jetzt etwas
zehn minuten und dann habe ich anderen
herd ausgemacht und sie etwas abkühlen
lassen
ihr könnt übrigens den mais und die
bohnen direkt mit dem hackfleisch geben
und auch höher mit einkochen lassen
ich habe es jetzt vergessen deswegen
lege später einfach oben drauf und hab
mir einfach noch eine schicht mehr
jetzt brauche ich noch ein paar andere
zutaten zum schichten und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier 400 gramm spanischer könnte
auch kein fresh lemon oder creme
schmecke ich dann gleich ab mit salz und
pfeffer und einem esslöffel essig hier
habe ich 400 gramm cocktailtomaten einen
eisbergsalat eine avocado etwas
limettensaft und hier habe ich noch
fetter käse und zwar nehme ich den käse
immer ganz gerne am stück und treiben
damit selber da habt ihr einfach keine
trennmittel mit trim das mache ich jetzt
kurz ihn in der küchenmaschine aber ihr
könnt es auch mit einer küchenrolle
machen
dafür schneidet dem käse in grobe stücke
dass er eben ihnen mixa passt das ist
jetzt ein bisschen mehr ich schreibe
aber gleich ein bisschen mehr weil ich
später noch ein anderes rezept damit
machen möchte oder ihr könnt auf den
käse einfach gerieben einfrieren kann
ich mal ein bisschen abend alle
charaktere durch ist vorbei
als nächstes schneide ich jetzt den
eisbergsalat klein und ich schneide ihn
erst um maschinen dann das geht einfach
ein bisschen ein warum und entweder
könnte dir sitzen oder in mundgerechte
stücke schneiden ich schneide ihn jetzt
in kleinen tödlichen
so die avocado habe ich es auch bereits
kleingeschnitten auch die tomaten und
zur avocado gebe ich jetzt noch eine
halbe limite rein also im saft einer
halben millimeter
damit sie auch nicht braun wird
jetzt habe ich fast alle komponenten
fertig jetzt muss man auch die stream
also dieser schmandt zubereitet werden
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach den essig
und gibt den mit dazu dadurch bekommt
ein bisschen säure dann noch mit salz
und pfeffer würzen
und dann gut verrühren
jetzt können wir den salat schichten ihr
braucht auf jeden fall noch ein paar
nacho chips und da hatte moratti
gesalzenen gekauft diesen auch ganz gut
so ich hab jetzt dafür eine glasschüssel
denn in glas sieht man das einfach
richtig schön vor allem von der seite
dann jetzt könnte das schichten da gibt
es auch verschiedene methoden des zu
machen
viele machen sich mit den salat ganz
unten rein aber ich finde dass salat
wird dann immer so zerdrückt deswegen
gebe ich jetzt ist hackfleisch unten
rein gespielt so leckeres verkäufe ja
wahnsinn und noch besser finde ich es
als sie jetzt zum anrichten wenn ihr
eine flache schale nehmt so eine
glasschale zum beispiel ich habe sowas
nur leider nicht denn dann sieht man von
der seite immer alles ganz gut und der
salat sieht einfach immer ordentlich aus
also der wird und später nicht so
durchgemacht aber das macht uns jetzt
nichts aus oder ich glaube es ist einer
meiner lieblings salate dann gebe ich
darüber die bohne und den mais mit
wenn schweine essen würden wir auch noch
speck mit rein gehen alle speckwürfel
kleine stücke in würfel schneiden kurz
anpassen dass sie hart werden und dann
als als avant über die tomaten gebe ich
jetzt die salsa sauce dies richtig schön
scharf und richtig lecker es müsste
natürlich immer alles schön bis zum rand
streichen
dann kommen die avocado dafür ein dass
zig genial aus dem mund zusammen
jetzt kommt der käse darüber
jetzt kommt noch der salat drüber da
gebe ich es einfach so viel drauf wie
halt noch ein fast ich meine mode ist
ganz recht wenn er viel salat reinpasst
die schüsse waren ist zu klein er passt
perfekt ehrlich glaube ich es wie von
oben bis unten durch ich bin immer sagt
jetzt ist das hat fast fertig ihr könnt
dann auch bis dahin sehr gut vorbereiten
und im kühlschrank lagern und dann kurz
vor dem servieren einfach noch die
nachos mit drauf geben
und weil wir den jetzt wahrscheinlich
gleich verdrücken oder sofa sofort geb
ich einfach jetzt schon mal die nazis
mit fragen warum nicht gleich also genau
weil ansonsten wenn du nämlich weich und
so zur gummiartig und ich möchte dass
die schön knusprig bleiben deswegen zum
schluss jetzt startete als wichtig bis
genug absolute lieblich salat wort
wahnsinn und dem rad hast eigentlich ja
wo ich mag keine süßen salate
rucola-salat nämlich ein paar metern und
balsamico ist richtig lecker
so jetzt gehört in sallach probieren und
am besten geht jetzt von oben nach ganz
unten weil es muss sich ja alles
vermischen und ihr braucht alle
schichten in eurem teller von um nach
oben wie ein bisschen schwer sich cook
dass ich alles mit rein bekommen
so sprach dankeschön
ich bin übrigens für eine party zum
beispiel auch ideal wenn man das direkt
in kleine schälchen abfüllt also man
kann sich zum beispiel in weckgläser
einfüllen und so schichten und dann hat
man direkt die richtige portion schüssel
nach meines lebens verlangt aber ich
finde die idee mit den weg lesenächte
richtig cool und dann kann man einfach
zum schluss zieht ákos oben draufsetzen
und ja 40 ging ja schnell möglich die
schlüssel des lebens jedes rad sowie nur
so lasse ich freue mich dass ich im rat
mit salat begeistern konnte ja wenn ihr
dieses rezept nach machen wollt könnt
ihr gerne auf meinen blog gehen auf
sally blog.de und ich freue mich wieder
aufs nächste mal wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen knuspert uhr ruhig
weiter da hört man dass er richtig lag
also viel spaß und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss